name's Chad Ward barbecuing expert he's
a competitor competitor grill master
where are you from grill master
pitmaster I am from the Imperial Polk
County Lakeland Florida okay but when
you compete yes sir
like what titles have you won we just
say a seven-time Grand Champion so we've
won events as large as the event in
Apopka this past year that was $10,000
grand prize to a couple of small local
events so we've cooked about a hundred
contests across 17 states how did you
know you were good at grilling that's a
great question I think it was just kind
of you I was all self-taught I gotta say
I love my dad he's a great father but he
was the master of it looks done on the
outside so it's done on the inside and
that was kind of not so much and just
kind of self-taught through college and
I just wanted to become a better griller
and I love to entertain so kind of
grilling entertaining goes hand in hand
what is the one thing I need to know
when I grill but if somebody's gonna
tailgate this weekend the one thing you
would tell them is you've got to do this
it is it is everyone always asks how
long and what temperature it really is
not how long it's the internal
temperature of the meat that right now
today if you just go out and get a good
instant read thermometer and cook to the
finish temperature of the meat you will
become a much much better griller than
if you just keep saying well it's on
there two hours it's got to be done
no let the meat tell you when it's done
but you can't eyeball that you cannot
eyeball that you you've got to have a
nice instant-read thermometer that you
know and I like to say I'm a moran of
preparation Dan so I've got one here you
know just pop it open put it in you know
if you're trying to cook a steak to
medium-rare when it says 135 pull it off
and let it rest the taking the meat off
and immediately eating it or immediately
cutting it up for consumption it's not
good you've got all these water
molecules bouncing around because of the
heat you take it off of that heat it
needs 10-15 minutes to settle so that
when you cook into it it's not like you
just open up the swimming pool for the
first time doing
and everybody's escaping give me some
mistakes that you hear with grilling you
know I I would say a big one is people
applying sauce way too early you know
they're cooking wings and the wings are
gonna take two two and a half hours and
they put the sauce on in the first 60 70
minutes and then they say well they
always turn out burnt
that's because sauces usually have a lot
of sugar and so I like to say if you're
gonna sauce your meat whether it be your
wings some pork chops the last 10 to 15
minutes of the cook if you make that
change you're gonna see you have a lot
better tasting meat do you have
trash-talking that goes along with
competitive grilling we do we do we it's
amazing work we're a huge family but you
got to talk a little smack here and
there you know maybe make fun of a guy's
money muscle on his pork but who knows
what's what's the money muscle yeah the
money muscle so if you if you look at a
pork butt you've got the bone end and
then you've got the other end and at
that other in there is the money muscle
and that if it's cooked correctly in
competition barbecue you slice it up
real nice and turn it into the judges
and if it's really good you're in the
money ever come close to fighting no
never that it's to family
there's too much family there there's
friendly trash-talking
but the barbecue community is great it's
like a second family
if you look at one of the great
organizations right now they're down
there with hurricane Matthew its
operational barbecue relief and and
really this is a group based out of
Kansas City but when something hits a
region you see that barbecue competition
family get together and respond and it's
just it's something you're proud to be a
part of he's Chad Ward is a barbecuing
expert and I know that you you cook with
the Trager grill yes sir okay he did see
my gas grill at my house and he said you
know what that's good for and you said
it is great for after you've triggered a
perfect meal you just throw it in there
and it's stainless steel and he just
keeps it warm - you ready to serve you
don't even have to turn it on cuz I came
home after yesterday's showing he had
been grilling at my house and he goes
open up your grill there and I thought
it was gonna be on I was gonna he's done
with gas grill and there was stuff in
there that was already cooked that he
kept in there and I went alright but you
teach classes don't you yes sir
I teach classes myself and then there at
Trager we've been going all across the
country with our barbecue shop class I
actually fly out of here tonight to prep
for a class tomorrow that we're doing at
my store down in Lakeland whiskey bin
barbecue supply and then I head up the
Alabama on Sunday we've got one in
Mobile and one in Huntsville next week
it's a lot of fun man being able to
share the passion and and what you know
and help people become better cooks but
also I would imagine if I wanted to beat
you I would just find out your recipes
do do people try to find out how you do
something I will share anything that
people ask because I'm still one of
those that I believe you know you can
sit there and Larry Bird can teach you
how to shoot a jump shot all day long
but you still you still got a square up
against him and knock it down with five
seconds to go and that's really the way
I look at are you the Larry Bird of
grilling no but I know I know I'm not
that girl mean I'm good but I don't want
to go bird status that's like a boyhood
idol there's some sacrilege in there
somewhere but um no I mean I just like
to be able to teach people about it and
then it's that really last four or five
minutes that you're preparing your entry
for the judges that's the make-or-break
time that's the difference in 10th
overall and walking away with the big
check that people haven't tried to look
through your garbage to see yeah that's
called shagging shigga shigga yes that's
a barbecue term of shiggin and so if
your Shiga meters up and you feel like
it may be happening sometimes you've
been known to take your rubber your
sauce you're using and put it in a
container so when you throw that
container out it's really not rub X it
was rub Y so sometimes you can kind of
lead people astray it's it's it depends
on what kind of mind games you want to
play best have you been to tell have
people rented you out for a tailgate I
have it I've done something for some
friends and family
I just love tailgating it's a great time
I love athletics love going to games and
I don't like a cold beer bourbon are you
allowed to have beer during competitive
competition oh if you didn't there
wouldn't be a there wouldn't be a
sanctioning body or an organization dan
how often does Paulie try to email you
or talk to you I'll tell you I mean I
would rape me and paulie's bromance at
about a 70
we do some texting and some direct
messaging back and forth it's but it's a
lot of fun man I mean it's cool to watch
these guys you know what were we
together you know five six weeks ago and
they ought you could tell they had a
passion for grilling and smoking and now
the more and more they get into it man
Hey look at this look at that I'm doing
this you got any ideas man I love that
it lights up my day well we're gonna put
up a recipe for this weekend okay for
people to tailgate yes sir and then
there'll be a link there for other
recipes that you have just did you help
people look I'm not good at it and
that's why I ask the questions but
you've said hey if you do this and this
and this you have a chance to you know
put off a pull off a good meal there yes
sir I think I mean me and miss Susan
haven't told you but I think I may be
coming up to that house and cooking a 40
pound hog like that yeah do you get the
ladies as a grill master you know it's
uh I don't want you back when I cooked
on those old dirty pits and I smelt
light like charcoal and burn up wood not
as much women didn't like that but that
Traeger you know it's kind of got that
sweet smell to it and it's kind of like
a little bit of a cologne now when I've
got the Trager smoke on me how about a
cologne we come up with it like a dry
rub Cologne I'll tell you I had some
buddies a couple of years ago from pork
barrel BBQ they came up with a cologne
called Q and literally and murdered it
Christmas you know and fathers yeah and
they killed it with it so uh it's been
done before they're just a pretty sharp
guys yeah I'm sure the neighborhood
animals would love that when you put on
that there would be women and be
everybody else all right your question
Paulie that you have 4chan I know you've
been a lot of tailgates down in the
south is there any tailgate any college
where you say that's a great place to go
for food at a tailgate go Gator oil I'll
tell you what I'm a gator fan but if you
want the best food in the SEC it's got
to be an LSU tailgate me and my pops a
couple years ago went to the College
World Series and Florida got knocked out
in the super regional Florida State got
knocked out in the super regional that's
his team we were both their men without
countries but we wanted to go to rosin
Rosenblatt before they shut down the old
one and man we made some friends with
some LSU
fans and not only you're gonna get great
grilled and smoked meat but you're gonna
get Chambal I are gonna get boudin I
mean they may throw batteries at Gator
fans from time to time but when you go
over there and you got a little smoked
peace offering
they're a lot of fun so I'd have to say
Pauly LSU and I'm probably gonna get so
much Twitter hey all right I know you
cooked for us during the live look in if
you want to see what it looks like when
somebody who's a professional does this
you're probably gonna be able to smell
this through the radio and TV it's that
good thank you again for your patience
whether it's been a lot of fun we've
enjoyed the Traeger grills and just
picking your brain hey thank you guys so
much for the opportunity it's a pleasure
all right you so Chad Ward barbecuing
expert will you have to service though
you have to let us know what we're
getting okay absolutely all right we'll
come back we'll close up shop after this
in the Dan Patrick show the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience